The original place
to invest online.
>> IF WE WANT TO KNOW WHO LEAK
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL' LONG LIST
OF QUESTIONS TO THE PRESIDENT,
WE NEED TO ASK WHO STANDS THE
MOST TO GAIN?
THE FORMER ASSISTANT TO BOB
MUELLER BLAMED PRESIDENT TRUMP
FOR THE LEAK BUT TRUMP BLASTED
THE LEAK HIMSELF IN A TWEET
EARLIER TODAY.
A REPORT IN THE WASHINGTON
POST SUGGESTED THE LEAKED LIST
MAYBE A SERIES OF REQUESTS
COMBINED BY A TRUMP ATTORNEY.
IT MAY HAVE BEEN A LIST OF
QUESTIONS THE PRESIDENT'S
LEGAL TEAM BELIEVED TRUMP
WOULD BE ASKED, KIND OF A MOOT
COURT SITUATION.
LET'S ASK TWO TOP LEGAL MINDS
WHY THEY THINK THE LIST WAS
LEAKED.
FORMER U.S. ATTORNEY FOR THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA AND
FORMER WHITEWATER DEPUTY
INDEPENDENT COUNSEL.
THE INTRIGUE, JOE, ABOUT WHO
LEAKED WHAT.
WHO HAS MOTIVE.
LIKE COLUMBO.
>> I ACTUALLY DON'T CARE.
I THINK WHAT IS IMPORTANT IS
THESE ARE CLEARLY THE TYPE OF
QUESTIONS DISCUSSED BETWEEN
THE PRESIDENT'S TEAM AND
MR. MUELLER, AND THE QUESTION,
WHAT DO THESE QUESTIONS SAY?
THEY SAY THE INVESTIGATION IS
NOW LURCHING INTO TERRITORY
PROTECTED BY THE CONSTITUTION,
THE CONSTITUTIONAL PRIVILEGES
OF THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AND MUELLER, LET'S
ASSUME THE QUESTIONS ARE
ACCURATE THAT. THIS IS WHAT
MUELLER WANTS TO ASK.
IF THEY ARE, AND IF HE INSISTS
ON ANSWERS, AND WILL NOT
ACCEPT A WRITTEN ANSWER AND
DEMANDS AN INTERVIEW, WHICH
THE PRESIDENT REJECTS, AND
THEN MUELLER INSISTS ON A
SPEEN , WE'RE HEAD TODAY A --
SUBPOENA, WE'RE HEAD TODAY A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS BECAUSE
THE PRESIDENT WON'T ANSWER
THESE QUESTIONS UNDER ANY SET
OF CIRCUMSTANCES.
>> WHEN I SAW TONIGHT THIS
REPORT IN THE POST ABOUT THE
PRESIDENTIAL SUBPOENA, YOU
KNOW IT TAKES KIND OF A LOT TO
SHOCK ME THESE DAYS IN
WASHINGTON BUT I TOOK A COUPLE
EXTRA BREATHS THERE.
YOUR REACTION.
>> I'M NOT SURE.
I SAW THE, I'M NOT SURE I SAW
THE POSTING.
IS IT ALREADY ISSUED?
>> NO APPARENTLY MUELLER
RAISED THE POSSIBILITY WITH
THE TRUMP LEGAL TEAM
REPORTEDLY.
>> I THINK JOE IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
IF, IF PRESIDENT TRUMP DECIDES
NOT TO SIT IN FOR THE
INTERVIEW AND ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS, AND THESE ARE VERY
BROAD QUESTIONS THAT
DEFINITELY RAISE ISSUES OF
BOTH EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE AND
SEPARATION OF POWERS, IF HE
DECLINES TO ANSWER AND MUELLER
ISSUES A SUBPOENA, YOU KNOW,
IT'S NOT JUST A QUESTION OF
DOES TRUMP INVOKE THE FIFTH OR
GO TO THE GRAND JIRX HE'LL GO
AND LITIGATE THIS ISSUE AND
HERE IS SOMETHING THAT IS VERY
INTERESTING THAT I DON'T
BELIEVE ANYBODY HAS TALKED
ABOUT.
REMEMBER, IN THE WATERGATE
YEARS, YOU HAD U.S. VERSUS
NIXON WHERE THE SUPREME COURT
REJECTED PRESIDENT NIXON'S
BLANKET CLAIMS OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, BUT IN THAT
DECISION, THEY POINTED OUT
THAT LEON JAWORSKI, THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL, HAD BEEN
EXPLICITLY GRANTED THE POWER
TO CON SEX EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
I'M NOT SURE BOB MUELLER HAS
THE POWER UNDER HIS
APPOINTMENT FROM ROSENSTEIN OR
THE REGULATION TO GO IN AND
CHALLENGE THE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE SO THERE'S A
POSSIBLE THIRD WAY FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO BOTTLE THIS UP IN
COURT ON THE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE ISSUE.
>> VERY INTERESTING.
I LOVE THAT.
ANY PARTICULAR QUESTIONS IN
THE LONG LIST JUMPED OUT AT
YOU AND WHY.
>> YES, THE QUESTION POLLSED
BY MUELLER ABOUT WHAT WERE YOU
THINKING WHEN YOU FIRED COMEY?
WHAT WERE YOU THINKING WHEN
YOU FIRED FLYNN?
THE NOTION THAT A SPECIAL
COUNSEL CAN INTRUDE ON THE
THINKING PROCESS OF A SITTING
PRESIDENT, WHILE HE WAS
PRESIDENT, FIRING A PERSON
THAT YOU HAVE ULTIMATE
AUTHORITY, UNFETTERED,
UNREVIEW ABLE AUTHORITY TO
FIRE UNTHE CONSTITUTION TELLS
ME ONE THING ABOUT MUELLER.
HE HAS GONE GOOFY.